we will do a sense check in a minute
because that's always something that i
recommend when you're doing
questions like this you do all this
working you crunch all these numbers and
then you end up with a nice neat number
at the end
however the reason i'm just pausing on
my sense check is because part a
very naturally leans into part b and
that's actually going to help us
do the sense check so part b says what
is the percentage of the shaded part
in relation to the whole area of the
dart board and that whole area of the
dart board which we're going to
obviously need to calculate
that's something which i think will help
us with our sense check so
the percentage of the shaded part in
relation to the whole area is just the
shaded part divided by
the whole area so let's work out the
area of the dart board
area of whole dartboard
and this is a nice easy formula of
course all the way back
from your seven times this is pi r
squared
and of course we're remembering it's the
correct radius which is the big one the
23
square centimeters so this is pi times
23
squared so i'm going to reach for my
calculator again pi times
23 squared so i'm getting
1661.2
dot dot dot and uh instead of rounding
at this point i mean i could round the
numbers are so
sufficiently you know different from
each other that it's not going to
introduce much of a problem
but your calculator can do this as well
it's not just desmos if you can use
exact values
then why not use exact values so this
guy over here
i'm going to call it let's say
a let's just name that guy a and i'm
going to call this guy down here
b if you didn't know that you could just
assign
values to things in desmos then here you
go you just call them by different
letters
and then i'll say a which is the shaded
part
i'm going to divide by b now that gives
us a very small number
um i'm trying to work out a percentage
and i've done this using the exact
figures so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to multiply by a hundred
and i get
this is the percentage not um that's not
you know multiplied by 100 again
i can say percentage equals
and i would because all of this
calculation that i've just done is kind
of hidden from my working because all in
the calculator so i would actually put
in these numbers that i used to
calculate it i'll go 4.98
dot dot dot i'm going to divide by the
total area that i just worked out
[Music]
1661.9025 dot dot dot
and what i'm getting is zero point
two nine nine seven dot dot dot
percent and uh they're asking
for uh the percentage to one decimal
place
so therefore this is going to round to
zero point
three percent to one decimal
place so i promised that we would use
this calculation here to help us do our
sense check
and it does though this is where i'm
going to refer back to the fact that our
diagram
it's like trying to be helpful and it is
but it's also unhelpful in a real way
when i looked at this number 0.3 i
thought
hold on this doesn't look right because
if you have a look at our original
diagram
that shaded section there looks a whole
lot bigger than point three percent like
point three percent
is very very small but that's why i
wanna remind you that in fact
if you have a think about this right um
this
section here this height uh is less than
a centimeter when the whole thing has a
radius of 23
centimeters so what you've got up there
i mean if you drew
lines in here to represent you know one
twenty third
of um this sector you would barely get
like a sliver at the top
if it was seven millimeters tall and so
you probably wouldn't be able to see it
doesn't make it a very useful diagram
but if you think about this more
accurately if i get rid of all of these
guys
now when you have a think about just a
line that's a sliver
like that actually point three percent
sounds like a much more reasonable
answer
after all and i've gone ahead i've
double checked and crunched my numbers
i'm pretty confident
that that that is indeed the percentage
okay so we've done a which is the area
of the shaded part
we just finished uh b which is the oopsy
daisy
um let's put that back where it was
before that's better
the percentage of the shaded part in
relation
to the whole area of the dark board and
lastly lastly
the perimeter of the shaded area so
i'm going to come back to my original
diagram over here it's getting a bit
busy but i think it's not
not too busy i can still use it how do i
work out the area
sorry the perimeter of this shaded area
well there's
four components to it or three as you'll
see in a second
you've got the length over here like so
that is unintentionally dark let's
choose a brighter one there we go
you have this length over here now what
is
that length it's not immediately obvious
because of the way that the
diagram has been drawn and the phrasing
the question but
that distance right there is actually
the same
as this distance here because that
point seven centimeters that um seven
millimeters is
it's going to be facing all the way
around in the same direction so if you
like i could say well
if if this is seven then so is this and
so is this they're all going to be seven
millimeters
so therefore um this i'm going to go
back to centimeters in a second because
that's the main unit i've been using all
the way through this question
that's 0.7 centimeters but by that logic
you've also got the same
0.7 hanging out over here so
those two sections are really just one
you can double them up
so those are the easy parts and then
you've got these other two in here what
color am i going to choose i don't think
i've used blue yet
so i've got this arc in here
over the top sorry over the bottom
rather so i've got to work out the
length
of that and then i also have to have
okay i'm rapidly running out of colors
i used green somewhere but i'll use it
again i've got this guy up here this is
another arc that is
as you can see from the diagram even
it's going to be ever so slightly
longer than the blue arc down below so
how do we work out each of these well
let's just take it one step
at a time um i've got ac and
bd down so i won't worry about them for
now let's worry about arc a b
and arc cd so let's am i going to have
space am i working i'll be a bit
cheeky and i will put it over
here on the left hand side
okay so part c what do we say so we've
got arc
a b now the length of an arc is another
one of these radian measure formulas
it is isn't as complicated as half r
squared theta in fact this is one of the
simplest formulas
that you can learn it's r times theta
that's it
radius of the circle multiplied by the
angle subtended
at the center and i know both of these
things for both of the arcs
this is the bigger arc first so it's
going to be a radius of 23
and i already worked out that the um
the angle subtended right in the first
part it's going to be this pi
on 10 that we have over here so
multiplied by pi
on 10 and in fact that's kind of it
23 pi on 10. i'm not even going to write
that because
you don't gain very much from it i'm
going to write it again later when i put
all these together
so that's arc a b arc
cd is going to be instead of a radius of
23 it's going to be 22.3 and then we
multiply by that same
angle pi on 10. so
there's the two arcs the blue and the
green ones up on the top of the bottom
and then i've got that 0.7 which happens
twice so you might notice as well unlike
in parts a
and b which you've asked for
approximation part c doesn't say
anything about approximation so we can
just leave this answer
exact i don't even need to do any
evaluation
beyond that so i'm going to say total
perimeter
equals let's do each of the pieces
it's going to be that 0.7 it happens
twice for each of the left and the right
edge then you're going to get the 23
pi on 10 and then you're going to get
the 22.3
pi on 10. so let's just
tidy it up ever so slightly this is of
course going to give us 1.4
i've already got them on the same
denominator so divided by 10
both of them so that gives me 23 plus
22.3 is
45.3
and there is a small part of me that
grates against having a decimal on top
of a fraction
so therefore i'm going to write this as
1.4
plus what do we got here 453
pi all over 10 and if you wanted to put
sorry all over 100 i should say if you
want to put this
all together then i guess that would be
140
plus 453 pi all
divided by 100 and our unit was in
centimeters
um of course if you want you can do a
quick sense check on that as well by
putting it into a calculator
seeing if it is reasonable i might as
well since i've just mentioned that
we could do it i might as well do it so
when we have a look here
uh what do we got here so 140 uh let's
do the fraction first 140
plus not minus plus 450
if i could type with my stubby fingers
453 pi that's the numerator
the denominator is a hundred fifteen
point
six centimeters does that sound
reasonable
at all well hopefully it is making sense
because remember
this diagram their diagram and my
diagram not to scale
if those two things are 0.7 but that's
actually very very
thin compared to the actual height of
this thing then
those two arcs do make sense to be
around like
six centimeters each because that scale
seems reasonable to me so i'm happy with
that answer of 15.6
so i'm going to leave that as my exact
solution